a woman's reproductive system
includes the vagina
cervix uterus
fallopian tubes and
ovaries
during vaginal sex between a man and a
woman
semen passes out of the man's penis into
the woman's vagina
in a process called ejaculation
semen contains tens of millions of sperm
from the vagina sperm can pass through
the cervix
uterus and fallopian tubes
to fertilize an egg from the woman's
body
fertilization of the egg marks the
beginning of human development
a birth control sponge is a temporary
method
for women to prevent pregnancy also
known as birth control
or contraception the sponge is made of
soft foam
it has a dimple on one side
and a short cotton loop attached
the sponge prevents pregnancy in two
ways
first the sponge covers the woman's
cervix to prevent sperm in the man's
semen
from entering her uterus
second the sponge contains a substance
called spermicide
that kills sperm
birth control sponges are widely
available without a prescription
to use a sponge wash your hands
and remove it from its package
wet the sponge completely with clean
water
squeeze the wet sponge a few times to
activate the spermicide
inside the sponge
next hold the sponge with the dimple
side facing up
and fold the sponge upward
with the loop hanging down insert the
folded sponge
into the vagina push the sponge as far
into the vagina as it will go
with one or two fingers when the sponge
is released
it will unfold and cover the cervix
check with your fingers to make sure the
cervix is completely covered by the
sponge
and the loop hangs down in the vagina
a woman can have sex right away or
up to 24 hours after inserting the
sponge
do not leave the sponge in place for
more than 30 hours
to remove it insert a finger into the
vagina
to find the sponge's loop
hook a finger in the loop and pull down
slowly and
gently after removing the sponge
throw it in the trash
a birth control sponge is about 90
effective at preventing
pregnancy if a woman uses the sponge
correctly
every time she has sex this means about
10 out of 100 women will become pregnant
each year
sponges are about 85 percent effective
with typical use
which means about 15 out of 100 women
will become pregnant if they don't
always use a sponge
or don't always use it correctly every
time they have sex
using the sponge does not protect either
sexual partner from getting sexually
transmitted diseases
including hiv